Hey.
How are ya'll doing today?
It's hot, right?
So, thank you all for coming to this room
and bearing the heat.
Hello.
So, this is a fun one.
I do this a lot.
If you have seen me talk before, I'm sorry.
I'm going to do it again.
But I kind of walk into the audience.
That's not good.
No.
Okay I'll do the short version.
I go like this and do this with the cat and
it will calm me down.
This backfired.
I'm not calm.
That didn't work.
Improvisation is a fun thing.
I'm Myles.
I work for Google as a developer advocate
on Cloud Platform.
This little line at the bottom.
This is all your talks.
This is my opinion, this is not my company's.
So, we're going to start with a quick glossary.
I use lots of terms.
ESN, ECMAScript module, CJS, common JS module.
Interoperability.
This is the ability to access ESN from CJS
and vice versa.
This is an important core concept of getting
Node on the web to play nicely and move forward
in a way that doesn't fracture the ecosystem.
Transparent interoperability.
This is a way to require ESN in CJS and import
in without knowing the type of the module.
The ability to use a module and then just
use ESN or CJS and not have to worry about
it.
This is how a lot of the transpilers work,
Babel or transpiler or Webpack.
You don't need to know the type of module.
A goal is a pairing of a top-level grammar
and a top-level execution model.
I'll get back to that later.
Bare inputs is the ability to require a module
by its name.
If you do require or import_, or vice versa,
to reference by the name of the module and
not give the full path is referred to as a
bare import.
Existential dread.
This is a feeling I get trying to get all
this to work and thinking about this problem
space.
And, you know, there are a handful of existential
problems we have in JavaScript, the language
right now.
Find me later.
We can have a beer and talk about it.
But how did we get to where we are today?
So, who remembers ES4?
It never happened.
The ES4 is introduced the concept of packages.
These were primarily based on C++ name spaces.
And the intent was to create something similar
to the Java jar system.
For those who don't know the joke, ES4 never
shipped.
We went straight to ES5 from ES3.
It was ripped out of the standards track and
never seen again.
All of these ES4 features just kind of vanished.
Common JS was introduced.
Members of TC39 worked on it, but it was never
standardized.
It was intended primarily for service.JS.
And we'll get into it in a minute and why
this is for servers and doesn't scale to the
web.
And NodeJS implemented a variant of the common
JS spec.
Who remembers AMD?
Keep your hands up if you liked writing the
files.
It's okay.
You all right put them down.
But AMD wasn't specified.
It was mostly implemented in require JS and
it was more of a convention than a standard.
And because of these things, we had a thing,
UMD to package them up to not think about
the modules.
UMD was the transparent interop of five years
ago.
But ES modules landed at ECMA 2.62.
We had modules and they were standardized,
but they weren't anywhere.
So, back to the glossary again.
What's a loader?
A loader is a generic term for a workflow,
fetch, transform and the evaluation hook.
These are the phases that happen when you
try to load a module.
When I reference a loader, it is an implementation
that does all of these things.
And this is where we get into like the first
really weird thing that makes things hard.
CommonJS technically doesn't have a separate
loader phase.
It has synchronous load and inline execution.
When you run Node and start a file, it starts
executing.
When you hit a require, it starts executing
that file and it does this synchronously.
When you try to load that file off of the
disk, it starts executing.
And it does that through essentially the whole
graph of your modules.
And this is why it's not really good for the
web.
If you have to wait for something to go over
the network, every single time you hit require,
and this isn't able to be done asynchronously,
you'll have a long time to wait until your
first paint.
Which is no good.
And I said there's no step, everything just
kind of happens.
And this is how Babel originally implemented
ESN.
People from Babel, you can find them afterwards,
and maybe I'm overstretching the implementation,
but they took the input statements, converted
them into require and then converted that
into files being linked together.
The original Babel loader was this in line
execution.
They changed to Babel when they implemented
the asynchronous model that was specified.
because they specify asynchronous load, and
these are different phases.
The module tree is figured first.
They may change the guarantees.
It is possible that the actual execution of
your graph could become asynchronous.
That's not what this talk is about.
Grab me at the party, I'll tell you about
this.
This is the fun part.
The loader is not specified.
It's implemented by the embedder.
The way in which it executes is specified.
The way in which the graph is crawled, and
everything is specified.
But how you actually load all those resources
is left up to the embedder.
There's been attempts to specify this both
at the W3C as well as the what working group.
But most of the processes at this point have
stalled.
And it's primarily being implemented and maybe
specified in the future.
I mentioned that load phase.
The load phase first goes and fetches all
of the texts for all of the module graphs.
So, it can go, it finds all the symbols and
all the things it needs to load over the network
and asynchronously grabs these.
And that goes with a concept like H2 push.
You can grab everything quickly.
It resolved the specifiers within the source
text and goes to the linking phase.
For the linking phase, the module graph, all
the files need to be in memory.
After they're in memory, they executed in
pre traversal order.
From the top down, it's linking the entire
graph.
This is important when you have things like
cycles.
If you have modules that are referencing modules
that are referencing modules it gets complicated.
You don't need multiple instances.
Everything in the graph is returning a singleton
when you're grabbing a keyword.
You import React in one file and another file,
you want that same version of React because
you want to register the components in the
same area or things get weird.
And that moves into the execution phase which
requires your link to be completed and is
actually done in post traversal order.
It starts at the roof nodes and goes to the
root node.
This is an instantiation phase.
You are going through the modules in the graph,
loading everything up into memory, creating
you will of the singletons so when you call
React later, it's ready to be used.
This is not something CommonJS needed to worry
about.
Everything is executing in line.
This is where things get weird.
They are not interchangeable, and it can result
in different execution order.
The exact same graph, defined by require and
then defined by input can actually cause things
to execute in a different order.
And if you're relying on the order that your
modules are going to execute, that can bite
you.
More behavior differences.
The specifier resolution algorithm is also
different.
so, TC3 leaves it up to the hosting environment
how to do specifier resolution.
That's the name of the module you're loading.
The specifier in the browser is a relative
path to things on the disk.
And in Node, this could be a combination of
relative paths or a bare import as we mentioned
before.
So, NodeJS has a specific resolution algorithm
for dealing with specifiers.
We support their imports, so you can import
low dash.
We allow you to impart JSON.
You can drop the file extension.
You can import a file with no extension and
import a directory.
Those are nice.
You can name a fail capability and then that
can turn into a directory with all sorts of
things in it later without you ever having
to refactor your code.
But this isn't exactly how things work on
the web.
The web doesn't support bare imports.
Currently the web only supports those paths.
You can only specify either absolute or indirect
paths.
If you had a module for Node, it's going to
blow up not browser.
There's a proposal, package name maps, to
allow a lookup process to find the bare imports
in the tree.
But it has a slightly different feature set
than Nodes model.
Specifically, you can do bare imports bub
you can also do deep module traversal by file
name.
The name of the file, slash, and a name of
the file deep in the tree.
But you can't import directories and you have
to give the file extension.
The reason is you don't want to be doing multiple
network calls for all modules.
In Node, this is fine, arguably.
It can be a problem.
If you import a thing without a file extension,
check, is it JS?
A native module?
JSON?
This thing?
Maybe checking four or five different file
extensions.
Those hits are cheap.
But not in the browser.
You don't want every module making seven or
eight network requests and going to the server
to respond and handling it 404s.
So, this kind of explicitness is necessary.
More behavior differences.
The code actually executes differently too.
So, we were talking about this before.
And ESN CommonJS run in different goals.
It was a mix of two different things and kind
of confusing.
Let's dig into it.
There's four types of goals.
You have script slip, script sloppy, ES module
and NodeJS.
You can see the goal, the combination of a
grammar and an execution mode.
Talking about a top level mode, it's strict
mode versus sloppy mode.
What symbol organize APIs, what is exposed
by the language?
Strict versus sloppy is denoted by a pragma,
strict.
Best practice five years ago and it still
is and removes capabilities from the language.
We don't want to break the language.
We don't to want change the way things work.
You can do it explicitly and it was often.
So, the chance of breaking things on the web
before was really low.
Now, the module goal, which was different
from both the strict and sloppy goal has different
changes.
You can't use HTML comments.
Who can actually use HTML comments in JavaScript?
So, you should change that.
Or it's going to break when you make modules.
A rate is a reserved keyword.
This was done by the committee to make sure
that the top level was something that could
happen.
And it may change over time.
That await keyword thing makes it hard to
use, you know, the any variable that's names
await.
It's not allowed anymore.
So, this is one of the really hard parts,
though.
ES modules don't have an in source way of
determining the goal.
Strict mode did.
You had a pragma.
These are just code, there is no pragma.
The committee decided not to use a pragma.
It's a new goal.
It's a new thing.
It's not progressive enhancement or de enhancement.
It's its own thing.
And you're using the browser and using the
type equals module.
There's no need to have the pragma.
In Node, we have no way of really knowing.
And there's also more goals that may be coming
in the future that are in the standards track.
This includes binary AST, Clarke in the audience
who is driving it that you can import Rosen.
That's ridiculously cool.
Web packages.
If you haven't heard, that's cool.
Bundlers work because you make a giant script.
But not for modules.
Because you can't just make a script with
multiple modules in it.
So, web package is one approach that would
allow you to bundle modules all together in
a way that could be understood by the browser.
And modules, another one that's nice to have
if you're, you know, doing modern web Dev.
JSX has a lot of this kind of inline ability
to make modules.
So, we have to pave the cow path.
We have to think, not just how do we make
ESN and CJN work together, we have to think
about a solution that works for any number
of infinite possible future goals.
And this is hard.
Especially thinking about interoperability.
If we're loading in Node, it's not the best
way of doing it.
You can't export the things on that symbol.
But you can require ESN.
It is because it has an asynchronous loader.
Grab me later and we can talk about the inconsistencies
there.
You can Google it's called zebra striping.
But moving from async to sync and back to
async, things get weird.
There's a lot of different ways to do this.
For Node's core modules, you can impart from
FS.
And as of 10.2, it's released about two weeks
ago.
You can do named exports from core modules.
But core modules in Node have an advantage.
Because Node is compiled, and we can do all
sorts of things in advance for it.
And if we allow it to import from CJS in the
ESN implementation, but not with named imports,
you only get the defaults.
And this capability makes it a little bit
more difficult.
The idea is not having to know the difference
between the type was modules.
But you kind of do because you only have a
default.
And this is one of the things that we're still
trying to work out.
Import meta require, something we're talking
about doing.
Import meta is the ability to put I'll talk
about it in a second.
But import meta require would allow you to
require C JS into ESN without having to worry
about transparent interop.
ESN does not have a way to include lexically
scoped variables.
It has lexically scoped variables.
And I start listing them and all of a sudden
it makes sense what a lexically scoped variable
is.
In Node, they're on Lamdba, and you inject
into the scope of the model.
These are not globals, they're specific to
the module.
The specific file name, a shared instance
of require and the module that's exposed.
All of these things are things that we inject
from, but ESN doesn't have that.
This is where import meta came in.
It's stage 3 at TC39.
A proposal by Dominik.
And allows run time to inject variables into
the module.
Inside of your module, you can say import
meta URL and that's a place for the file name.
And that's somewhere you can hang your file,
for example, to have essentially have a back
door to allow you to get the CJS modules in
without
a transparent interop.
[skype breaking up] ESN file, file extension.
We're going to need that no matter what.
Even if we allow JS the ability to do a solution
to say, hey, this says that the ES module
is necessary.
Even if you just say Node, thing.JS.
That's the way you are able to boot into an
ES module.
We have support for and support for transparent
interop and ESN, but no support for transparent
interop in JS.
With the async loader, it's currently not
possible.
But we're exploring options in a way this
would actually work.
And we have support for dynamic import in
both ESM and CJS.
You name a module, it returns to a promise
to resolve that.
Top level will make this really great in ESN.
But currently the top level await spec is
not targeting the script goal.
It's not an enhancement that is available?
CJS.
We have support for import meta.
But currently only exposing import meta URL.
And some of the decisions have made some people
grumpy.
And in response, we spun up a NodeJS modules
team.
We made it open and 42 members signed up in
the first week.
This included representation from at least
ten countries including Canada, China, Germany,
Israel, Italy, Japan, Nigeria, the United
Kingdom and South Africa.
And the U.S.
We have representation from ten corporate
organizations including Airbnb, Bloomberg,
GoDaddy, Google, Groupon, IBM, Microsoft,
Mozilla and nearform.
And Node source.
I'm off by one in all of these.
It's a big problem in technology.
14 programming platforms you know, Angular,
Babel, Bloomberg, jQuery, JSPM.
Lo Dash, tap JS, V8 and Webpack.
But as you can see, we've got a lot of people
who are working on all the tools that we're
using trying to work towards consensus.
Trying to make sure that this is happening.
And we have representation from three of the
standards bodies.
We have people at TC39, the working group
and people at W3C.
This one was really easy.
There's only three of them.
But we're all really hard at work on this
problem.
This is a really, really hard problem.
And doing it right is this kind of existential
thing.
If we do it wrong, we could create this like
irreconcilable like schism in the community.
And we all take this really, really, really
seriously.
And I know that probably every single person
in this room is worried about this being done
right.
And the whole purpose of this talk, I was
hoping to kind of just show under the hood
a little bit of like all the things that make
this really hard and really weird and really
tough.
But I wanted to reinforce to all of you that
like all those people, all those 42 people
from all those companies, all those fronts,
and all those standards bodies, we are pull
our hair out.
We are working really hard.
Biweekly meetings, giant threads.
You can't even keep up.
Trying to bash out a solution so that you
can just keep writing code and not have to
worry about this.
And I really, you know, in the next year,
year and a half we'll be able to ship something.
My dream is that you can npm install something
and run in the browser or Node without the
build step.
Which would be in my opinion absolutely amazing.
And with that, here's a surf dog.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]